c'est des parisiens ils veulent
davantage et de la campagne sans les
inconvénients à la douce mélodie de la
campagne mais que tout le monde m'aime
pas et que certains voudraient même
faire taire déjà en 1969
un couple de parisiens voulaient faire
taire les cloches d'une église près de
fontainebleau
enfin il me semble qu'il ya d'autres
brouillard commandant a empêché plus
avant de se mettre dans de s'attaquer
aux cloches au delà du conflit de
voisinage c'est un problème plus profond
de cohabitation entre ruraux et urbains
certains le prenaient à la rigolade
comme ce maire ayant fait d arrêter les
citadins devons entendre les grâces paix
s'ils ne peuvent pas les écouter avec
plaisir les bruits de la vie naturelle
et sauvage existe encore ou ces
villageois en 1996 venant soutenir le
coq renato au tribunal le gallinacé
était accusé par ses voisins vivent en
résidence secondaire de chanter trop
fort est trop tôt pour les villageois
fortement mobilisés le plaignant un
parisien devrait tout simplement se
trouver une autre basse cour remplie
pourquoi pas d'automobile pour d'autres
terminée la plaisanterie
aujourd'hui les gens viennent à la
campagne ils veulent imposer leur loi
alors qu'on est arrivé avant eux que 80
en ville on respecte ce qui s'y passe à
eux aussi de respecter la campagne mais
pour certains urbains qui ont leur
résidence secondaire à la campagne ou
même pour quelques touristes difficile
d'entendre ses arguments one more open
windows quand vous ouvrez la fenêtre la
nuit il y à 40 de décibels c'est plus de
15 décibels au dessus de la normale ce
bilan bien est toujours le même blocage
faute sérieux on est en montagne
moi quand je vais à paris je dis pas
qu'on arrête le bruit d du métro quoi
ces conflits se terminent parfois devant
les tribunaux mais plus étonnant et
n'ayant peur de rien certains demandent
même l'extermination pure et simple des
auteurs des nuisances comme par exemple
les cigales de provence mais qui a donc
demandé d'exterminer les cigales la
patronne du café a sa petite idée
je crois que c'était de parking
le parisien qui se plaignent du bruit
des cigales sur le baudet cidal c'est là
l'un sur quoi tout que les boules quiès
pour ce genre là serait plus
intelligente elle est massacré ces peaux
d'animaux
comment ne pas y avoir pensé plus tôt
les boules quiès tel un calumet de la
paix entre ruraux et urbains
[Musique]